zeen then she says far-right extremism
in eastern Germany is a very serious
threat her views of attracted so hooked
but also hostility he looks like it is
an East German a Social Democrat and the
federal government Commissioner for
Eastern German affairs and she's our
guest this week on the DW interview
welcome Ostreicher hello head and a warm
welcome to our viewers my name is
Alexandra phenomena Ella's glycol is
far-right extremism and Eastern German
problem known as this kind no it's not
restricted to eastern Germany but
considerably more far-right attacks
occur in eastern Germany than western
Germany has a vest Oakland the eclairs
and East German yourself can you explain
why this is as well especially amongst
most I got kind of there are various
explanations on the one hand it's rooted
in disappointment lack of prospects this
is how efficient then people look for
scapegoats in the stretched fat this is
by no means an excuse but we need to
bear it in mind it's okay neznam um dim
final minute first you know I earlier
this year I commissioned a research
study to explore the phenomenon in depth
um smirk lousy person chef they don't
home alphabets a lesson what was the
outcome yeah given is a leading on if
the results are not yet available
they'll be published next year but I
believe we need research on regional
differences also fake yawn alaba's on
diet and my laughs awesome quite as far
right extremism such an acute problem in
some places and less so in others on
parham is a sadness well I'm really
looking forward to the results be nice a
grand Oh Javier Kipnis huh the compass
that fool but a study you commissioned
in 2015 showed that eastern and western
German attitudes aren't actually that
different even regarding an issues such
as an a phobia a quantified so have
things changed in the last year dr. Stan
if and when we can I hope test lets me
Alice I've a melon we've recently
experienced in Dresden how a real decay
of political culture can come about
Sakura and yet been with a massive
people gathering and denouncing
democratically elected politicians as
traders to the nation's democratise a
democratic converter put it together
non-political and that's folks for that
iota was she going on about the lying
press and yelling abuse of diplomats
simplifies to get lost and getting hold
up hold up that's a genuine decaying
stuff and this is specific to eastern
Germany in ostrich land on the surface
man appel off but even in eastern
Germany these people are a minority Mia
hide the majority of people in eastern
Germany are neither xenophobic nor far
right but they have become a silent
majority and I would appeal to them to
speak out to me I don t miss la vie just
probably mhmm when you outline the
problem in your report this year on the
state of German unity your critics
accused you of exaggerating one
newspaper suggested eastern Germany has
become a pariah do you feel like a
traitor to where you come from this
Bushnell 79 foolish machine issue that's
no I don't yet für das deutschland
what's going on there is highly
detrimental to eastern Germany give a
high matsu leaden hoddan madam
ambassador the very people who profess
to love their country are abusing
foreigners and destroying political
culture una district coupe and causing
serious damage to eastern germany
deutschland course in chardon nice I've
identified a problem but that doesn't
make me the problem son and a gift ism
we need to support people in eastern
Germany who have been speaking up about
far-right extremism for years went all
entries in dresden for example there's a
group of young people who sing hymns
demonstrations as a way of countering
all the yelling gizem is in blue on bus
and getting Suzette's that's an
expression of hope and that sort of
thing needs to be supported clavel
unterstützen see chromium closing in a
small town in southern tiering in with a
population of about five thousand that's
also where your constituency is but in
the past the region has frequently made
headlines as a neo Nazi stronghold
what's your experience of the region
found him it come acted on yeah the NPD
well years ago the neo-nazi NPD made my
hometown a front line which is not see
language to start with pasilla don't but
people resisted happen once kuvira Devon
boon miss King and I sixth when we set
up an association against far-right
extremism under the aegis of the church
from high shaft out pavan God sent it
comprises a number of parties active
does his club
I believe it's very important that
society takes a stand we're not truly
wise obviously I was part of this
association I took part in one
demonstration on the central marketplace
and used a megaphone to declare it our
marketplace just spell out that we
didn't want neo-nazis their food is good
food us you know it was good to see the
older and younger generations coming
together to take a stand against
far-right extremism about all he could
but the challenges remain and also in my
hometown the silent majority must speak
of twitten on Moses Clabo King what was
in this immense but who are they these
people going to events like neo-nazi
concerts are they people you might have
known or are they people who come from
outside also hope ur da hemolysin as I
was by this no they're both obviously
everyone knows one another in rural
areas in small towns we know who the
neo-nazis are definitely kidding via but
there are others who come from outside
and then and then climbs didn't got kind
of flag but it has to be said they
wouldn't be going there if there weren't
already neo-nazi activity going on
bendini fought Octavian and there's no
two ways about it Lord to comment as
most Malkin's class and come on if
you've known these people for years
can't you talk to them it's as a chapter
of our hunger masters in my experience
they're pretty bad people they're
fanatical doesn't feel you can't have a
sensible conversation with them station
I'll go men yeah of course Lawson I have
no illusions Mike minutes for tots Tim
be but I'm not willing to give up on the
ones who are just going along with it
CCS ones who have been duped by
populists ideas was auction game on
madine missin via disco they're the ones
we need to talk to to show that there
are no simple answers to complex
problems oh yeah the good Pope we have
to show these rabble-rousers for what
they are and that requires political
resolve poultice we need to be firm we
need to reclaim our credibility and for
that we need to take a clear stand and
translate our words into deeds does Kate
nua and invert una vez was a gonzaga's
Fatone is the actively campaign against
far-right extremism did something
happened that made you say I have to do
something cool I just far yeah that it
was a response to the demonstrations in
my hometown when a whole gang of jnana
is march through closing in with
torchlight seat and also the populace
pegida demonstrations all fasta expo
police station these people are riding
roughshod over my principles the idea is
that gave rise to the peaceful
revolution of 89 my media or stuff they
might demonstrate on a Monday but let
there be no mistake they have nothing to
do with the original Monday
demonstrations kind of more task than
one stunt that's much longer so yes
these events were a turning point the
demonstrations in my hometown and in
neighboring towns Martin we need to take
a stand from the outset stetina ninga
mine own mom was fun and Sun can't at
songkhla md arrests openness that you've
mentioned the far-right populists pegida
movement there's also the AFD the
alternative for Germany party which has
a lot of support in eastern Germany why
do you think these movements are doing
so well via cleanses us escaped escaped
often escapes us there's a growing
skepticism toward politicians and the
media on that partly explains it
district-wide that MIT so to not does
not to list promises were made that
weren't kept or at least not yet
resolved an online guide problems are
often swept under the carpet man smile
zuku tan but SVO shown alles ganz schön
champion my made reference in my report
to the profitability yet often the
difficulties of the transformation
process and the hardships people endured
as a result of the East German economy
being d industrialized in my dad
dentistry elysian there is widespread
unemployment that Sophia every family
was affected I'm you buying that sort of
thing changes the society and we need to
face up to that windows must burn and
Vietnam desmos alpha male and I can't
Viet still it's no excuse it doesn't
justify a single attack a single riot
uber kind of people i vish get a status
but i do think that our politicians need
to acknowledge what eastern Germany went
through these are an acronym that was
taught realized oh yeah tortoise Mahan
was that's just do you think they
haven't done so now yeah as happy and
well I've heard it all politics tends to
veer between saying everything is
wonderful and painting the most gloomy
picture possible by this is neither is
the right approach
and neither do justice to what's
actually going on safin Borden is that's
why I believe in telling its drapes me
adopting it Subin then it might not suit
everyone but I can live with it than all
critique our server dammit conosco
tongan this is India you've had abuse
hold at you when you've spoken in public
including on your own constituency on
the marketplace in your hometown you've
been threatened do you ever fear for
your safety the safety of your family
it'll familia as I've been looking just
a few fear is a very oppressive feeling
I've feared for my child for my parents
more so than for myself Oh me socia thus
but the ISIS interfere yes it's not
pleasant to be at home when a bunch of
neo-nazis start surrounding your house
neo-nazis it's very uncomfortable the
central nani maka fula doesn't fazool
hoe its clear laser attempts to silence
people who are taking a stand that's all
I can do is link arms with others and
say okay this is horrible when talk but
we're going to survive it we're not
going to give them any leeway lessened
in kind home when he's estudian a
representative survey from 2015 showed
that twenty five percent of people in
Turing and have far-right sympathies
it's given statistics like that does it
still feel like homes i had signed and
also horsham yeah it sharper yes it does
I have wonderful friends and family
young when there are so many people
young and old who are taking a stand
against far-right extremism yes assuming
the survey is right seventy-five percent
of people do not share these far-right
sympathies and that's the seventy-five
percent that needs to close ranks the
film 150 I know how hard that is slice
but there is no alternative a bus black
[ __ ] an eternity whoa sumptuousness TV
always end the DW interview with three
sentences that I'd like to ask you to
finish guys that's it once or 15 even
when I meant old to my son about
communist East Germany then commish me &
mines my phone I sometimes feel like my
own grandmother's I'm [ __ ] it's a long
time ago let me put it that way yes mom
it's where I grew up and he was born
around the time the Berlin Wall fell so
to him it's all ancient history and it's
good that my son hasn't grown up with an
east-west distinction of mine zone
nishma and is most West leaped is he
interested in that time at all yes to me
german reunification means fly high
freedom I'm once Tim oakley fought for
democracy and freedom ABBA but of course
we started out with huge optimism that's
we hope the reconstruction would go
faster davidoff Paul schnell a key
nevertheless our achievements of the
last 26 years are incredible one globe
is I'm very proud of them insects in
Spanish on on dot hospital Scott is
finished I'm proud of my home state
cheering him because my dog was at the
cement its home two wonderful people
wonderful landscape at lunch after
father they're a great business is based
there I kept on van and if we stand
together against far-right extremism and
right-wing populism then more tourists
will come and we'll give them a warm
welcome out to the santevia all gonna be
a coma myosin give us like it thank you
it's done thank you